cuando vemos protestas en los medios de
comunicación normalmente nos pasan
imágenes de llantas quemadas de piedras
que vuelan por los aires vidrios rotos
pasajeros indignados las personas que
salen estas imágenes no son
y consideradas ciudadanos sino
pobladores agitadores e incluso
delincuentes pero debemos tener en
cuenta que cuando hablamos de la
protesta en realidad estamos
refiriéndonos a un fenómeno que viene
expresándose a lo largo de la historia
de la humanidad y que ha servido para
lograr conquistas muy importantes para
las personas por ejemplo me viene a la
memoria este cuadro famoso desde la cruz
la libertad guiando al pueblo verdad la
protesta ha servido para conquistar
derechos para conquistar la jornada de 8
horas el voto de las mujeres para acabar
con el apartheid y también en el perú la
protesta ha servido por ejemplo para
lograr la aprobación de la ley de
consulta previa entonces pero más allá
de su importancia histórica y de la
relevancia social de la protesta es
importante que todos sepamos que cuando
hablamos de protesta estamos hablando
también de un derecho humano
y lo ha reconocido la organización de
naciones unidas el sistema
interamericano de derechos humanos y en
el perú incluso el tribunal
constitucional emitió una sentencia muy
importante sobre este tema en el año
2020 reconociendo que el derecho a la
protesta es un derecho que forma parte
de la constitución pero con algunos
límites el límite principal es que la
protesta solamente puede ser realizada
por métodos pacíficos porque la protesta
por definición tiene siempre un elemento
disruptivo un elemento incómodo un
elemento perturbador esa es la
naturaleza de la protesta pensemos por
ejemplo en las jóvenes feministas que
los últimos años salen a protestar para
reivindicar derechos sexuales y
reproductivos y utilizan sus cuerpos
desnudos como herramienta de
reivindicación pensemos en los
colectivos de la diversidad sexual por
ejemplo en un acto que es
popular en los últimos años la llamada
beso ton en algunos momentos incluso por
ejemplo esos colectivos se han ido a
besar en las puertas de la catedral de
lima y algunas voces indignadas han
sostenido que estaban perturbando el
orden público pero en realidad están
olvidando que por naturaleza por
definición la protesta social tiene
siempre un elemento disruptivo ahora
esto no significa que dentro del derecho
a la protesta puedan justificarse actos
de violencia es decir es causar lesiones
a otras personas
causar daños a la propiedad pero lo que
sí ella justifica es el bloqueo de
carreteras el corte de vías bloquear una
carretera puede hacerse de manera
totalmente pacífica no desde por si una
acción violenta
además pensemos que hay diferentes
actividades de nuestra vida en común de
nuestra vida como sociedad que involucra
el corte de carreteras pensemos por
ejemplo el año pasado los juegos
panamericanos o pensemos
el cierre de carreteras para que pueda
pasearse el señor de los milagros
también la la comisión interamericana de
derechos humanos se ha pronunciado sobre
el tema del corte de carreteras
indicando que en un sistema democrático
las vías públicas las carreteras cumplen
diferentes funciones cumplen una función
que es la más obvia de servir para el
ejercicio de la libertad de tránsito
obviamente pero también las vías
públicas sirven para ejercer la libertad
de expresión a través de la protesta y
ambos derechos deben conciliarse
inclusive dice la comisión
interamericana el derecho a la protesta
la libertad de expresión es aún más
importante que la libertad de tránsito
porque es algo que conocemos en derecho
como como un derecho instrumental eso
qué quiere decir que sirve para proteger
o defender otros derechos no como lo
hemos visto recientemente en perú
el derecho a la protesta a la libertad
de expresión ha servido para defender la
democracia también recientemente el
derecho a la protesta se ha utilizado
para reclamar pagos justos para reclamar
el cese de un régimen laboral de la
agroexportación que llevaba ya 30 años
con los trabajadores del campo en
condiciones de explotación pero el
bloqueo de carreteras tiene que
someterse a algunos controles para esto
hay una herramienta muy importante que
tienen los operadores de justicia que se
llama el test de proporcionalidad el
test de proporcionalidad permite poner
en una balanza cuáles son los derechos o
intereses que están involucrados
entonces tenemos por un lado la libertad
de tránsito de las personas que quieren
desplazarse por ejemplo por la carretera
panamericana y tenemos en el otro lado
el derecho a condiciones de vida digna
por parte de los trabajadores del sector
agrario claro uno podría decir pobre
señor no está viajando para regresar a
su casa y tiene que pasarse varias horas
varada en la carretera eso evidentemente
no es un plato del gusto de nadie pero
comparemos este malestar de algunas
horas con una situación de explotación
que lleva ya 30 años en el país una
situación de explotación que no se ha
podido cambiar con nada que no se ha
podido cambiar con acciones judiciales
en una situación de explotación y que
los medios de comunicación no ven no es
una situación de explotación que afecta
a miles de familias en el perú y que
lleva ya 30 años que pesa más que es más
grave evidentemente es
lo más grave es lo que lleva a las
personas a movilizarse ya bloquear
carreteras esto no es algo que la gente
haga por diversión lo hacen porque no
les queda más remedio porque ya han
utilizado otros canales pero nadie les
hace caso
entonces utilizando el test de
proporcionalidad podemos ver que es más
grave la afectación que está llevando a
las personas a salir a las calles y por
lo tanto ese bloqueo de carreteras es
amparado por la constitución y las
normas internacionales pero hay algunas
situaciones que siempre deben protegerse
incluso en un bloqueo de carreteras que
es legítimo debe siempre garantizarse un
corredor humanitario lo que no puede
pasar es que hay una persona que está
haciendo por ejemplo trasladada porque
se le complicó una mujer al momento de
dar a luz y necesita
ser atendida en un hospital de cierta
complejidad pues tiene que poder pasar
por la carretera y eso lo debe respetar
todos los manifestantes aunque sus
demandas sean legítimas pero esto es
algo que normalmente hacen los
movimientos sociales en el perú aunque
los medios de comunicación no lo
mencionan por ejemplo en las protestas
del paro amazónico que culminaron con el
llamado baguazo la gente no lo sabe pero
el paro amazónico no solamente se dio en
amazonas en bagua el paro amazónico duró
dos años inició en el 2008 toda la
amazonía se levantó para defender los
territorios indígenas del expolio del
saqueo y culminó así con el baguazo
en la llamada curva del que se
hizo famosa por razones terribles que
todos conocemos verdad la muerte de 15
ciudadanos a las que luego se sumaron
otras tantas en la estación 6
los indígenas awajún y wampis que eran
los que viven en esa zona habían llegado
a una decisión muy sabia ellos abrían la
carretera cada una vez al día para
permitir el ingreso de víveres y que
pasaran a los particulares en sus
vehículos de manera que nunca se
generará desabastecimiento en la ciudad
vecina que era la ciudad de bagua grande
y eso le generó la simpatía de la
solidaridad de las personas en la zona
urbana que incluso les llevaban sacos de
arroz les llevaban víveres para que
pudieran continuar con sus luchas
entonces
los movimientos sociales en el perú
tienen esa experiencia y tienen también
esa solidaridad de no generar
afectaciones
graves a otros ciudadanos e incluso en
situaciones de bloqueo de carreteras no
solamente que los medios de comunicación
no lo suelen mencionar
incluso en el código penal actualmente
está incluido el delito de extorsión que
permite condenar a 25 años de prisión a
personas por el bloqueo de carreteras
esto ya lo ha solucionado el tribunal
constitucional pero miren comparen 25
años de prisión por bloquear una
carretera para que te paguen un sueldo
justo
y bueno menos de 10 años por matar a una
persona manejando en estado de ebriedad
es completamente arbitrario no es cierto
pero afortunadamente en esta sentencia
del año pasado el tribunal
constitucional ya estableció que no
puede condenarse bajo este tipo penal a
los manifestantes sin embargo siguen
persistiendo varios problemas y el
principal de ellos es el abuso de la
fuerza por parte de la policía en
situaciones de protesta social lo hemos
visto hace poco en lima y eso nos ha
conmocionado dos chicos inti y brian han
muerto defendiendo a la democracia pero
esto es pan de cada día en regiones esto
es pan de cada día donde viven las
comunidades nativas o las comunidades
campesinas en la sierra y en la costa
del perú en nosotros en la coordinadora
de derechos humanos tenemos un registro
y desde el 2003 hasta el día de hoy 166
civiles han muerto en protestas y la
mayoría ha muerto
disparos de arma de fuego que no debería
llevar la policía cuando va a controlar
movilizaciones sociales aquí en lima a
los jóvenes les han disparado canicas en
la sierra en la selva le disparan con
ametralladoras esto es una situación que
no puede continuar en una democracia la
policía existe para cuidar a los
ciudadanos existe para garantizar
nuestros derechos y no puede bajo ningún
concepto convertirse en nuestra víctima
área por esa razón es que hay ahora
mismo un movimiento social muy fuerte
una demanda importante que exige que se
lleven a cabo una serie de reformas en
la policía sin duda un problema que debe
afrontarse en esta reforma es el de la
corrupción pero a otro problema central
es el del uso desproporcionado
indiscriminado de la fuerza esto debe
cambiar deben garantizarse en primer
lugar equipos adecuados para el control
de manifestaciones no más canicas no más
y ametralladoras todos los policías
deben tener los equipos adecuados que
permitan un uso diferenciado y
proporcional de la fuerza en segundo
lugar un entrenamiento adecuado a los
policías a veces lo que ha ocurrido es
que simplemente no estaban preparados
salían al terreno de operaciones se
asustaban mucho no por la situación de
estrés que es realmente en ocasiones muy
fuerte no están en medio de un disturbio
por ejemplo y su reacción por falta de
entrenamiento era sacar su pistola y
disparar a la gente no en tercer lugar
todas las operaciones deberían ser
grabadas y los policías deberían tener
identificaciones visibles como el número
de un jugador de fútbol que se pueda ver
a distancia porque hay un fenómeno que
está muy bien estudiado el anonimato es
una condición psicológica que nos lleva
a cometer abusos si tú sabes que no te
van a poder identificar es mucho más
fácil que cometas abusos o que violen
las normas en cambio si tú sabes qué
tu nombre va a ser rápidamente
detectable pues te vas a cuidar mucho
más antes de cometer cualquier
irregularidad y por último lo que
estamos solicitando es que se
fortalezcan los mecanismos de control
administrativo dentro de la policía no
puede ser que con 166 personas
fallecidas no haya ni una sola sanción
por parte de inspectoría de la policía
algo está mal algo está fallando y esto
debería de cambiar no solamente para
sancionar a los policías que hacen más
las cosas sino también para detectar
cuando hay fallas dentro del diseño de
los procedimientos la policía entonces
este mecanismo de control administrativo
también debería tener un carácter
técnico no solamente sancionatorio bueno
ya para concluir nunca más debe volver a
haber un muerto en protestas en el perú
muchas gracias
y